okay let's make a start I can see lots
of happy faces so I guess you're all
enjoying the conference but I'm not
that's not your fault
not the organizers for it's not the
speaker's fault it's not more wasteful
all of those things are great it's my
own fault I've got something on my mind
I need to make a confession when I was a
junior developer I was the world's
biggest expert beginner in just one year
I had it all figured out no one could
tell me anything
now it's not because I was arrogant okay
I was arrogant but that's not the main
reason the main reason is I just wanted
to feel important work on interesting
stuff like the seniors I'd see them
standing at the whiteboard doing the big
architecture staff stroking their chins
drinking coffee and eating cookies
talking about distributed systems
message buses continuous delivery all
that fancy stuff and I'd be there fixing
CSS bugs like I wanted to do the
important stuff it wasn't that I was
arrogant I just wanted to feel important
and be like the seniors and so I try and
get involved in their conversations and
make myself look senior oh yeah that I
can see where you're going with that
architecture just a bit of wucf here and
a bit of silverlight down here
perfect and completely future-proof hey
Nick we've got a CSS book can you
quickly go and fix it but then one day I
found something that would transform me
into a senior developer overnight I was
walking past the bookshelf in the office
and I saw this book and I knew straight
away this is the book
professional business objects perfect I
want to be professional I want to do all
that business stuff I want to write
objects in my code that do professional
business e things so I'm just looking at
this book and convinced the next day I'm
going to come back to this office as a
senior developer and those seniors
they'll be fixing my bugs in that moment
I felt invincible for about three
seconds
one of the senior developers comes over
and he starts laughing he's like no you
don't want to read that book
it's it's not great and I'm thinking to
myself wow this book is so good he
doesn't even want me to read it because
he knows what's going to happen if I
read it but then he says wait wait read
this book instead domain-driven design
am I hang on a minute I don't want to be
a designer I have like no artistic
talent I can't your smiley faces or even
stickman it's like Nick it's a book
about software design okay he says look
if you read this book you'll be glad you
did ten years from now I don't know
about ten years from now ten minutes
from now I'm reading this domain-driven
design brooch and I'm having kind of a
hard time I mean the first chapter is
kind of interesting where this Eric
Evans guy sits down with domain experts
and they're modeling this software and
constantly tweaking it yeah that seems
kind of cool then you flick a few pages
and there's tons and tons and tons of
UML everywhere and puns and tons and
tons of a both Java like who did this to
me but let's play a game let's imagine
if we did fast-forward 10 years from
that point what would happen would
anything change would he be right would
I be wrong surely that expert begin I
couldn't be wrong about anything 10
years from now could they actually I was
wrong and it is kind of a useful book
and I have grown quite an appreciation
before as I dipped in and out of it over
the years
but I'm not here today to take you on
that journey of mine I'm here to look
forward because I think there are some
topics and hidden trends and insight in
this book that we've kind of missed that
will be more useful now and in the
future than they were 15 years ago when
that book came out now I just said
there's tons and tons of you amount of a
post Java in that book how could it
possibly be useful in the future give me
a chance to dig myself out of this hole
please five minutes so let's look at a
few trends we're seeing currently in
tech so biggest trend I'm seeing is
Valeska monetization of infrastructure
like we're not looking down
infrastructure and how many projects
have you worked on where infrastructure
was the problem and you spent so much
time to trying to get server setup that
problems going away now and Amazon's
automating it oh and and Microsoft
they're doing a bit too but these big
cloud companies are automating
infrastructure and that means as
developers where we spend our time where
we make a difference is changing and we
need to move up the stack as well and I
don't just mean the front end what I
mean is over the past decade or so
product management has evolved as well
movements like the Lean Startup we've
started seeing oh this is how we build
products in the Internet era and what
we're seeing now is that the best way to
improve products is to talk to your
customers and the second best way is to
let your teens make choices about the
product and so what we're seeing now in
some of the leading companies is a
process called continuous discovery and
delivery so we have a cross-functional
team developers testers all that stuff
and they're continuously delivering work
but at the same time
that same team is constantly talking to
customers developers are getting
involved in user research and that same
team is taking that feedback and
deciding what it wants to build I'm not
talking about that stuff today there are
some great books the loads of talk you
can go and check out if you're not
familiar with this process
it's something I'm seeing a lot of in
the top companies and I'm convinced it's
going to happen become mainstream so I
would recommend these books but there's
one other trend I'd like to talk about
and that's the type of systems we're
building so we micro service is a bit of
a buzzword but that is typically the way
we're moving we're building systems with
lots of small pieces in them hundreds or
even thousands of micro services like a
project I worked on a couple of years
ago but evened the shape and the type
and the flavor of those pieces is
different we've got hundreds of
different kinds of devices now we've
started with desktop and we're but then
phone and tablet and now we've got light
bulbs crackers microwaves everything's
on the internet and this the number of
devices is growing and growing and
that's changing the kind of systems we
build in a way we need to think about
building them I'm currently working for
a client in New York you have these
devices installed on the streets of New
York and London and rolling out around
the world and it's been completely
different for me understanding how all
of these things can fail they can go
offline and come back on later and like
I wasn't prepared for this in my code so
it's been it's been a change and I've
had to adapt and I'm sure more
adaptation will happen that was this
light oh no it's not this is this slide
so what I'm getting to is I think these
changes were seeing I think the hidden
insights in the DDD book prepare us for
these changes so the hidden insights
that we haven't noticed so I'd like to
start with exploration so when we build
systems what we're looking for is
sustainable evolution we need to build
software now to make money tomorrow but
we need to keep evolving those systems
so they continue to make money well we
get to the stage where we have a huge
monolith changes take ages know what
gets done and the company suffers I was
recently working for a big company and
they had a massive engineering team but
their codebase was so bad they couldn't
keep up with their smaller competitors
this codebase was
so bad it had four home rolled message
buses in the same codebase and one of
them stored its publisher and subscriber
configurations in the Windows registry I
thought that's funny
but anyway how do we well I thought it
was funny after I left not when I was
working in the codebase that's for sure
so how do we build the sustainable
evolvable systems it's solid the answer
may be how about testing creating
comprehensive test Suites so we can make
changes and we know when things fail
maybe
how about modularity getting boundaries
right so different parts of the system
are isolated I don't think that's enough
see what I found is we need to
understand the domain we can have nice
clean code but if we have the wrong
abstractions or the wrong names that
kind of complexity can be equally as
painful as not having tests and so I've
got this great quote in the book which
is the first model you create is going
to be very naive and superficial and in
my experience it always has being very
naive and superficial and then as you
want to evolve the system the
refactoring is you should be looking to
make or based on your improved knowledge
of the domain we've represented this
concept wrong this abstraction isn't so
good let's change it based on any
knowledge but in my experience that
doesn't really happen because most
developers skip the discovery part of
DDD myself included but I don't blame
developers because in the book there are
no recipes every just talks about I got
with some domain experts and didn't um
oh I tried that didn't work for me I
look like a complete idiot
the main experts completely switched off
had no interest in issue and now stuff
and I've tried other things like
meetings and whiteboards but they're
useful up to an extent to the point
where people fall asleep but whiteboards
also have limitations you've got one
person
the pan everyone uses their own kind of
scribbles and notations it's it's the
best we had kind of until this man came
along
Alberto Brandolini the savior of the
main German design because he invented
something called event storming anyone
heard of event storming okay cool so
everyone who hasn't heard of event
storming I've taught you something super
important today so why is event storming
useful so what what is it basically you
get a bunch of people together ideally
people from your company different malls
developers testers UX all different
domain experts a mixture of people
ideally people from different teams you
put them in a room with no chairs and
they hate it so add some chairs back
later no seriously they hate their give
them lots of coffee and donuts and you
give them some orange post-it notes and
you say to them
model your domain as a time line on the
wall so you've got this massive wall
space perhaps like this room here maybe
if you're lucky and so everyone have
these orange post-it notes there's a
matter where you work in the company
what your role is or your background you
can take an orange post-it note you can
explain a part of the business process
that you understand you can stick it on
the wall so if we were doing the
conference proposals the conference
submission process you might have call
for papers open talk proposals submitted
call for papers closed talk accepted I'm
not used to that one too much but you
get the idea and so that's that that's
the first round we just do orange
post-it notes on the wall as a timeline
everyone can do this we're not looking
at a whiteboard and people have
conversations at the same time then we
want to add more detail later so we can
start adding other detail and we
typically do this in iterations so we
might start adding users and external
systems and then we might add commands
and then we might start adding things
like money and the user experience how
do people feel here so you're modeling
the domain
and you're adding additional information
from your users your business context to
build up this rich rich picture of the
process and so I feel like after ten
years finally we have this process where
you don't need to be an expert draw or
sketch or you just need some orange
post-it notes and any developer can
model their domain with a domain expert
and get a rich knowledge and I think
we've seen event storming has become so
popular for this reason I'd like to talk
about a few of my personal triumphs so
the first one is you want to bring your
team closer to the business if you're
properly doing domain driven design you
want everyone in your team to take the
knowledge of the domain and use that to
improve your software you don't want to
rely on the team lead it something like
your proxy domain acts but you're on the
whole team to be close to that and with
a venn storm you can absolutely do that
you get your whole team close to the
business there are some caveats
different kinds of personalities but
when it works it works really well and
also you're not limited to a whiteboard
you've got like a huge wall space you
can model your entire process you can
start connecting the dots oh we have
this problem over here and someone else
says well we could fix that all the way
over here you start getting these
insights and I see this every time I do
event stormy what else do we have
and so as a developer if you don't want
to bore people with UML with event
storming you can typically have a good
workshop for a couple of hours the time
will fly normally people start saying my
feet hurt now can we have some chairs
that's how much fun you're having so you
can you can have these collaborative
sessions that last for a long time and
also I feel personally when I do event
storming I feel like I'm properly
understanding domains I feel like what
I've been doing for the past seven or
eight years I didn't really know these
domains and my models in code was so
naive in all the business saying that
would and it's in my code I'm doing DDD
no I'm not I'm just an idiot I'm not an
idiot but I'm not doing proper DDD with
then storming properly getting into the
domain and so what what's the hidden
lesson here domain discovery is
fundamental to DDD I think that's
obvious from the book discoveries about
discoveries the key to building
evolvable systems I think that's kind of
obvious to is it's the answer event
storming no because that wasn't in the
book 15 years ago so those aren't hidden
lessons whoops
not sure what happened there here we go
back on track so this comment from Eric
is what I think points to the hidden
lesson so look at the language he uses
here knowledge of the model should
pervade every medium of communication he
wants us to properly immerse ourselves
in the domains like he did he think
that's he thinks that's how we get the
true benefits of ddv so I think the
hidden lesson here is that we should all
be looking for better ways to explore
domains with the main expert event
storming is a great start but I think
there could be even better techniques
and I'm sure there are better techniques
even Alberto himself says event storming
says pizza and you can add any topping
except pineapple but I like pineapple so
add lots of pineapple and if you want to
learn more about event storming there's
some resources here and as an example of
some other techniques we see now we're
seeing things like the main storytelling
which is also quite useful so that's the
first that's the first hidden lesson the
second one is calling this section
design and so this starts back again
when I'm a junior so I'm working on this
project me and a senior developer I'm
pairing up with him and we're working on
this new feature to implement promos and
special offers in the legacy code base
and so we start off by doing some
whiteboard sketches with the domain
expert in this case whiteboards okay
because there were just a few of us then
we go back to the code and he says we're
going to use an anti corruption layer
here so we're going to wrap the legacy
code in this layer and we're going to
build our own model on top and we'll do
the translation and so we work in these
iterations do a bit of discovery with
the domain expert at the white board go
back to our code up they add a nice
model do the translations to the
anti-corruption layer and over a couple
of months we start chipping away at the
old the old legacy and adding our new
stuff on top and at the end of this
project I feel like I've got to work on
some interesting stuff and not just CSS
but I learned some
this this anti-corruption law patter
seems really useful when you're working
with legacy wrap it in an
anti-corruption layer and put your nice
clean model on top so some months after
this I'm paired up with a different
senior working on a different project
still with lots of legacy and he says
okay Nick I've heard you were trying to
similar project before I'm gonna let you
I'm gonna let you start this one you can
go up the code and do whatever you think
is necessary so I'm like right outside
in TDD and an anti-corruption layer
because it worked on the past project
it's going to work on this project a
couple of hours later I've made a
rightness and the codes getting Messier
and Messier and I'm like no the
anti-corruption layer works it's me
that's wrong excuse me and the senior
developer says okay this is and this
isn't going too well let's get a coffee
let's come back later so we go for a
drink we have a coffee we come back and
then he says I don't think it's time for
an ACL here I think we should try
something a little bit different and so
he takes the keyboard he takes over I'm
the I'm the passenger and he starts
being something completely different
he starts writing some tests around the
existing code and then he starts
refactoring stuff in lining stuff
deleting classes and after about a day
we've gone from like 60 classes down to
about 15 to 20 classes and then we start
adding our new features into the
existing code right well that's not what
we did where's the antica optionally I
didn't understand it and so sometimes
sometimes you want to wrap the existing
mess but sometimes you want to clean it
up first and so what you end up with is
this pattern legacy lasagna oh we're
going to implement any featuring this
code base let's rap the old messy stuff
and put a nice clean stuff on top six
months later a different group of
developers oh my god this is a mess
let's let's put a corruption layer on
top of this and then add a nice clean
model on top Mike had low calls this the
lava layer anti-pattern it's got a good
post on that but my my
intrigued from this experience was how
do these senior developers know when to
use certain patterns and principles and
techniques because I was convinced the
anti-corruption I was the right thing to
do here and I've seen this over the
years where developers become attached
to like dry yakhni
all of those principles it works in one
place and we want to use it everywhere
and so again I think this comment from
the book made me realize that no yet
there are no perfect solutions to every
situation there's nothing you can take
from one experience in guarantee it will
work in the next so that's my hidden
lesson here let's know there's no
heuristic you can always rely on to make
the perfect decision in any situation
and I found this out the hard way and
this there's a guy called matias vera
from the ddv community and he's got this
quote he says don't look the
confirmation bias look for heuristics
and principles that give you doubts
about your choices that try and make you
think I've made a wrong choice here so
here are some heuristics on the dhih
dhih dhih book so a common but a common
heuristic is look for language as a way
to identify boundaries in your code if
you have the same word that has
different meanings in different places
maybe maybe that's a good place to put
the boundary or look for the same
concepts with different names or
different concepts that are really the
same thing so they're known as
duplication of concerts and false
cognates and also make the implicit
explicit I was reviewing a pull request
the other day and there was this flat
that the format was like a flat format
of data and like we could expose that to
the user or we could group these
different bits of data and add some
meaning on top of them make the implicit
explicit make it easier to understand
and evolve and over the years I picked
up a lot of heuristics in the DDD
community and from other people and here
are a few of my face
so my favorite heuristic is the money
heuristic and this tells us look for
different parts of our code base and
understand how valuable they are to the
business let's put a bound let's
separate high-value stuff from low value
stuff if you're familiar with BDD you
might recognize these as core domains
but if we do this we can invest in the
high value things without having to
spend money on the low value things that
are coupled to them another heuristic is
to marry me heuristic I'm not proposing
to Jonathan this is the name of a
heuristic so this heuristic says when
you have two parts of your code and they
know about the internals of each other
they're so tightly coupled they may as
well just get married another one is the
t1000 heuristic so if you've seen the
movie Terminator T there's this cyborg
that comes from the future - not a
cyborg of robot comes back to destroy
this guy who's going to destroy the
robots in the future anyway they try and
kill this robot and attack it and shoot
it but his body just keeps reforming and
there's this one scene where they freeze
it and they smash it into a thousand
pieces but its body just reforms and
comes back and comes back and I'm trying
to kill them and I've seen this in code
bases where we have lots of different
logic that's scattered all over the
place but it really wants to belong
together so use that heuristic and ask
yourself do we have bits and pieces
everywhere that really belong together
another one is the Erlang heuristic so
our line is all about isolating things
so that when they fail they don't cause
other parts of the system to fail and we
can use this as a general heuristic the
way we design systems think about at the
business level so if this part of the
system fails what would be the
consequences to the business should we
isolate those things for those reasons
and my favorite heuristic is the Game of
Thrones heuristic so Game of Thrones
right everyone knows Game of Thrones
surely so Game of Thrones one of the
best TV shows ever all these different
clans and gangs of people they all want
to sit on the throne and really this is
just an analogy
of your organization everyone wants to
climb the org chart and sit at the top
and so when you're designing software
you have to be careful that you're not
affecting the power the power structures
in your organization so if you take if
you create a boundary which involves two
teams becoming one you might have taken
headcount away from a manager and now we
have less power in the organization
you're going to face friction to doing
that I've got some previous talks about
this in digital transformations if
you're interested but to learn more
about heuristics and I really recommend
you do learn more about heuristics
Rebecca and Matias they've got some
great talks and some great resources and
they've got hundreds of heuristics that
I know you will find useful and I've
actually got this brilliant quote from
Matias that always makes me laugh when I
see it I was saying to him once like I'm
doing these modeling sessions sometimes
and I'll just use a heuristic and people
think I'm a genius and I'm like I'm just
asking a simple question and he says to
me like I'm not a genius consultant I
just have better heuristics and that
applies to all of us we don't need to be
geniuses we just need to know the list
of heuristics that we can ask the right
questions or find those hidden insights
so moving on to the final topic now I'm
calling this section organization so
this is going back to I've progressed in
my career and I'm kind of a junior and
I'm working on this project where two
parts of the organization are merging
there are about three teams on our side
B teams on their side some bits of the
code on marketing but some bits are
being rewritten and it is not a great
project constantly crossover between
teams people changing one part affecting
the other team so we get to this
situation when we're having meetings all
the time and the project manager says we
have to have a meeting every day all six
meetings having a meeting every day and
that's not including stand-up and when
you get to these meetings there are a
lot of big egos in there everyone
standing you up saying do things this
way do things that way
and I'm not enjoying this project and I
know everyone's feeling this project is
going to fail and so one evening after
work I'm walking to the London Erlang
user group and I'm telling my colleague
who works in a different part of the
organisation like yeah all the meetings
shared libraries teams getting in each
other's way
this project is going to fail can you
get me onto your team and he said well
what hang on a sec what merge conflicts
shared line briefs teams breaking each
other's stuff aren't you doing DDD right
yeah I'm pretty sure we've got ends fees
and value objects and all that stuff you
won't I think you need to go back and
read that section on bounded context
again some right okay thought I
understood bounded context anyway we go
to the user group and then they go home
that night and I'm scouring the DDD book
what's this what's this hidden insight
he's leading me towards and I get to
this story where Eric's talking about
these teams that are having all the
problems we're having I'm like could
have just read the book and solved it my
own problems but yeah these teams are
making changes affecting each other all
these kinds of coordination problems and
then there's a bit where Eric talks
about a bounded context is about one
team for bounded context and he says
bounded contacts are a way to geek up
all the parts but those parts are teams
and on this story he says they had
different models but they didn't realize
it and I'm thinking oh yeah we've got
this model and we're all cuddled to it
multiple teams we've already failed
bounded contexts and so I go looking
through the code and I notice there are
some scenes in this shared module where
we could easily break this down into
multiple models and I think this is so
obvious why did I not even see that in
the first place I mean the cohesion here
it's quite obvious why why didn't we
just do this in the first place it seems
obvious now I know what I'm looking for
so I'm looking forward to that big
meeting the next day telling all of
these people I found the answer to all
of our problems so I get to the meeting
goes on the table all the big folks
stand up and put their opinions across
and then at the end I'm like I've got
something to say and then I go on and I
tell them about the multiple models my
epiphany with the buck and all that
stuff and they're like you don't know
what you're talking about you that
rubbish
we spent ages ages creating this data
model and now you want to go back and
change it all I tell you that was not a
nice day and I kind of I felt properly
embarrassed in that meeting everyone's
looking at me I just wanted to cry and
I'm like right I'm not I'm not going to
say anything else on this project I was
going to keep my head down and get on
within but I've always had this kind of
mischievous cheeky streak about me and
that night had an idea in the shower had
a few actually so I'm in the shower and
I'm starting to think wait I don't need
to convince all of those six teams like
I know the people I'm working with on my
team they're not enjoying this project
they know it's going to fail and they're
they're feeling as much pain as I am if
I can just convince them and we can just
can decouple ourselves from that shared
module maybe our lives will be better so
getting the next day I start telling
them about this idea and they're very
they're like yeah we saw what happened
in the meeting yesterday we don't want
to be we don't want to be happy having
that happen to us either but they're
like yeah well we know the project's
going to fail and we're not enjoying it
so and then one person says well why
don't we just try try it for like a
sprint so we did for the next couple of
weeks we tried decoupling ourselves from
the shared module and it turned out to
be we did it about nineteen ninety-five
percent and we were happy with that and
then we didn't tell the other teams
which they all kept going for those
meetings we did dare not tell those
other teams we dare not tell them and
then probably a couple of Sprint's after
that at the demo session we had stuff to
demo we started demoing stuff and
management loved it like all finally the
project's taking off and it's all taking
shape amazing the other teams they were
still talking about
data models and architecture diagrams
and we were demoing stuff and then the
other teams they they kind of worked out
what we were up to and they weren't
happy within and they went to management
and tried to get us in trouble and make
us go back to the old model but
management were like no they're demoing
stuff they're delivering stuff let's let
them continue and a few months later we
were completely finished on that project
we did all of our stuff probably about
5% maybe we still had a few dependencies
and we still had to wait for other teams
to finish but we did most of our work
and the CTO is like they're still months
away from finishing I need you to go and
help them by whatever means necessary
well not whatever means necessary not
quite a drastic but we were called in to
save things now I want to be clear here
that the point of this story I'm not
saying you should go rogue and do things
your own way and create another silo in
the organization that wasn't the goal
here we didn't want to do that but it
taught me a lesson along the way that
bounded context and software
architecture and technical choices it's
all about decoupling the teams we can't
really think about what we're doing in
software without the effect on the teams
and since that story I've worked in many
organizations we're creating technical
boundaries separate from creating team
boundaries and I see these problem
playing out dependencies across teams
conflict politics I think it's time we
started making an effort to do better on
that and so when you go back to the DVB
book you realize that that whole section
on bounded context is all about
decoupling teams everything in that
section he's always talking about teams
use bounded contact city couple teams
you see quotes like this and this and
this it's all about teams and so what we
call software architecture I'm going to
realize that it's really socio technical
architecture thinking about teams and
technology when we make those choices
now I don't want to quickly I don't want
to talk about this too much but
I do want to give you a process for
finding boundaries there's no there's no
flowchart there's no six steps to the
perfect boundaries or anything like that
those fitness videos you can buy but the
process I use that most of the time is
start with event storming model your
domain get those in the details and get
a joint view across different teams when
you have that visualization then you can
start looking for boundaries and
creating context maps and then then you
use the heuristics you try the money
heuristic the marry me heuristic the
gaming furniture istic and you challenge
your challenge your architecture and
look for alternatives and then you have
to do this regularly as you build
systems and they evolve the coupling
changes as the business strategy changes
as new management comes in that affects
which parts of your software system and
your teams are changing together so you
have to do this regularly and I thought
I thought this was a pretty useful
hidden lesson about the teams and at the
main German design Europe last year I
gave a talk about this and I said to
people you might want to think of
bounded context as autonomy context
think of them that way about creating
autonomous teams and this guy called
Eric Evans came up after my talk and
he's like I didn't really like what you
said there about calling them those
things I was like whoops and then the
next day he was giving the closing
keynote and he said I had this keynote
figured out weeks ago but then I saw
some in this conference and I need to
put a record straight so he says bounded
contexts I'm sitting there like in the
second row where you are and he's saying
this and like he's talking about me so
yeah that was kind of walk but you can
watch his keynote as well if you do
watch it just think about me looking
like an idiot in the audience so I'm
pretty pretty much finished now I want
to go back to what we talked about at
the start so how do those stories and
hidden lessons how do they affect us
moving forward so if we think about
continuous discovery and delivery it's
about us as developers making product
decisions and when we talk to customers
we don't just build what customers are
asking for it doesn't work that way it's
about us as developers understanding
what customers are asking for and
understanding what the business needs
and it's about us making those decisions
those product decisions and when we do
event storming and we get that close to
the business and the business process
and how we make money where users not
happy that gives us the knowledge to
make those decisions
and because we're not going up the
organization chart to get sign up on
decisions we can move much more quickly
as organizations but it relies on
developers being closer to the business
and the customers the second one was the
complex systems as I talked about
earlier I've been caught out on this
project I'm working on by thinking about
us dicks that worked for me in the past
if we want to be prepared for this next
generation when we have all these IOT
devices architecture with much smaller
pieces we need to be prepared to adapt
our ways of thinking and the best way to
do that is to have a big toolbox of
heuristics and you're constantly saying
for myself how could my design be wrong
which heuristic makes is my design
invalid or incorrect and finally if we
don't have alignment between technical
boundaries and team boundaries and teams
having a high level of ownership and
autonomy we're just going to be stuck in
politics and meetings and I don't think
any of the other stuff really matters so
based on the trends I'm seeing based on
these insights I've shared with you I'm
convinced that in just a few years from
now so what we think of as software
developers will be product focused
socio-technical thinkers so now I'm just
wondering what will you be thank you
are we doing if anyone has any questions
feel free to come over